in a world where the most popular video
games are online there exists a better
class of criminal
not again don't do it please
rogues who refuse to play by the
digitally coded rules
five villains who can be as absurd as
they are disruptive I just killed the
cheater what the [__] dude who the [__]
that just killed yo we're talking of
course about hackers this [__] guy's
cheating hacking was seemingly first
used to describe experts in early
programming in the 60s but the sort of
hacking you'd probably recognize really
came together in the 80s both in reality
and with the advent of cyberpunk in my
senior year I went to class and the
first assignment was to write a program
to find the first 100 Fibonacci numbers
instead I wrote a program to steal
passwords and the teacher was so taken
aback with this program that I got an A
and a lot of attaboys and the ethics
taught when I was in high school was it
was okay to have as technology improved
hacking became the art of breaking into
secured systems it was seen as a kind of
counterculture led by a group of
rebellious pranksters who understood the
laws of the internet and how to break
them better than their suit-wearing
rivals but it wasn't just movies of the
80s and 90s that were fetishizing
hackers RPGs and video games were also
proliferating their cool image
but I've got nerves of steel anyway
that's how hacking became a cultural
phenomenon but how did it start to
affect video games well for as long as
button inputs have existed developers
have included hidden cheat codes to give
players strange ways to enjoy their
games but in the 90s devices like the
game shark and game genie emerged
enabling players to actually modify game
data whether it was invincibility
infinite lives or unlocking hidden
characters Nintendo even tried to sue
the various regional game genie
distributors claiming that the device
and fringed under the copyright but they
lost that battle anyway by the end of
the 90s tampering with the game's code
transformed from a harmless pastime into
a genuine threat to its competitive
integrity all online multiplayer titles
like Starcraft and counter-strike were
among the earliest to showcase the
growing hacking problem basically
everyone who played CS back then
encountered a hacker for some people
hacking was even seen as cool a kind of
prankster is trolling that made people
freak out until an admin arrived to deal
with it hacker clans like my god became
notorious for ruining people's games and
harassing their victims when they got
upset the reactions to hacking were
immortalized in the actually pretty
[__] up flash video I hate you my god
- oh my god you [__] loser I know you
hack the infamous hacker group even
duped gullible fools into thinking they
could join by baking cakes that said my
God owns me this of course was a lie and
just another way to own people while
using custom software to gain an
advantage was annoying that was pretty
much the extent of it at the time while
some servers had leaderboards there were
no inclined competitive ranked modes for
games
so hacking was mostly a prank early
eSports competitions just did what they
could
people could be accused of cheating but
coming up with definitive proof was
harder in eSports hackers weren't using
obvious cheats to turn them into
spinning sniper rifle tops of
destruction they were doing what became
known as legit hacking a term that arose
in the early 2010's to describe the use
of advantageous tools like aim lock that
were subtle enough to go undetected by
the mid-2000s anti-cheat systems like
vac and punkbuster had been introduced
to clamp down on hackers but even they
were in full truth essentially there was
an arms race going on between the people
creating the hacking tools and the game
developers and fan communities that
wanted competitive integrity but these
games are complex pieces of software
with many potential vulnerabilities and
as eSports prize pools continue to grow
hacking became an increasingly serious
problem hackers began selling their game
breaking wares to players who weren't
interested in playing by the same rules
as everyone else and thanks to the
number of hackers out there today people
are quick to throw around cheating
accusations in eSports in late 2014 the
Counter Strike global Offensive
community was wracked by a series of
competitive player bans through valve
anti-cheat some were banned mid-game
wolf with the AWP he's out in Russia
wilderness just sniping did immediate
just get back band oh god what did what
did we just see I yeah others like Kalle
left their team and their competition in
terrible situations out of game what the
[__] he was playing victim what the [__]
he took my [__] place perhaps the
highest profile incident was more recent
though optic India's star player
forsaken was caught using an aimbot at
extremes land Asia disguised on his
computer as word Exe as you can see here
the locking is very similar to what
happens over at the B site earlier on
the game when he locks on the guy's back
except this is even more blatant because
not only is he locking on the guy he's
locking on the guy and following him
through the box many fans believe that
using hacks in a land was impossible so
when it turned out the forsaken had done
it before it shook the seams faith
tournament organizers forsaken was
slapped with a five-year ban from the
eSports integrity coalition which
partners with companies like ESL and
Dreamhack he even gave an interview
where he said he thought his
decision-making was very good but he
wasn't confident in his aim which is why
he started hacking not Omni i h8 you
know gutless cheat as well okay so
clearly hacking is a threat to eSports
but how can it affect you when you're
just playing your favorite game csgo
specifically had a big issues when the
game went free-to-play the cost of
getting caught became the time it took
to make a new accounts scripts in League
of Legends can be surprisingly
disruptive they can show where champions
are given millisecond perfect ability
casts and even help evade skill shots
and today there are ranked matchmaking
cues in nearly every popular online
title which means that hackers throw off
the balance or even get paid to boost
people using their cheats developers
continue to fight back though
for example Ubisoft recently implemented
a rollback system that reverses the
result of any match with a proven hacker
and while initiatives like this are a
step in the right direction the siege
community still hopes that more can be
done horrible some needs to happen
really bad about it
I mean ie Logan play it happens at least
three times out of ten games
Ubisoft really needs to crack down on
that it's getting progressively worse I
don't know whether that's on boobies
back in or there's hackers and finding
more and more innovative ways or even
the youtubers to do the siege blitz
videos so I think what they're doing now
from what I'm seeing is going after that
you know the people who are getting
boosted and some of the root causes of
the hacking and not necessarily the
hacks themselves and I think that could
be the right Avenue here because again
it's of the day it's a cat-and-mouse
game I never think that you're gonna
completely eradicate it from any PC game
but if you can get rid of the the people
who want to do it and the reasons for
them to want to do it then that'll be a
better situation as it stands hackers
look to remain an infuriating part of
all our favorite games for the
foreseeable future and although there's
no situation for getting rid of them
most developers and communities continue
to fight side by side to minimize their
chances of ruin
are fun well we could have gone a lot
more in depth than we did but that seems
like a pretty good miles is obviously
the better host miles are you supposed
to be hosting the show what does it look
like I'm doing laughing creepily by
yourself
Touche it in order if you if you
caricature Josh and I admit it's a
caricature
if you caricature Josh it very quickly
becomes this like not to say California
surfer but something not far
don't make sure there will be better
things for the employed
[Music]